c'était un engagement phare du
gouvernement trudeau
aujourd'hui nous fermons le marché des
armes d'assaut de type militaire au
canada mais neuf mois plus tard un
chapitre reste à écrire celui du
programme de rachat pour compenser les
propriétaires des armes d'assaut
interdite
radio canada a appris qu'un projet de
loi sera déposé au cours des prochains
jours pour le mettre sur pied
or le programme de rachat ne sera pas
obligatoire les propriétaires pourront
conserver leur arme mais ne pourront pas
les utiliser et devront respecter des
conditions d'entreposage streep et
sécuritaire début de rachat obligatoire
selon le bloc québécois c'est une
occasion ratée non seulement les césars
mais là vont rester dans les maisons
mais les gens vont pouvoir les utiliser
même si même si c'est bon interdit de le
faire
on sait qu'il ya des gens qui le font
pour faire baisser la pression
les libéraux profiteront de l'occasion
pour proposer de nouvelles mesures pour
améliorer la sécurité des communautés
l'une d'elles donnera à la police ou à
des professionnels de la santé le
pouvoir de donner l'alerté lorsqu'une
personne peut représenter un danger pour
elles-mêmes un groupe identifiable ou un
partenaire mais certains élus comme la
mairesse de montréal attendent plus
beaucoup plus oui les armes d'assaut en
amont heureux mais je le demande pour
les armes c c'est un fléau en ce moment
ce vil et encore ébranlé par la mort de
l'adolescente de 15 ans mary mbounda oui
tu es en fait semaine lors d'une
fusillade dans l'arrondissement de saint
léonard
elle réclame qu'ottawa bannissent ou si
les armes de poing à l'échelle nationale
ça n'a pas de sens qui légifèrent les
armes se prend même la pression venant
des villes place le gouvernement trudeau
dans une position encore plus
inconfortable
il veut à tout prix éviter de répéter la
controverse du registre des armes
d'épaulé qui a hanté les libéraux
pendant tant d'années en contexte de
gouvernement minoritaire
saura-t-il trouver l'équilibré et
convaincre ou
un des principaux partis d'opposition
que ces mesures sont adéquates ici
louisbourg et radio canada ottawa